good to see you both look at all the
great hair in that room look at all the
great hair in that room what
you can thank our hairstylists
you've done a great job and might i say
you as well sir you're looking quite i
am i am really trying i'm really trying
but here we are guys one of the best
things about being an audience member
who who loves umbrella academy is that
you're always surprised by the surprises
like you can't tell where things are
going to go when you sit down and you
read that script how often are you guys
getting that sensation especially like
third year in
i'm i was incredibly surprised reading
the scripts this season
i think we have like the best just at
least for me these are certainly my
favorite episodes that i've written we
go to
all of us we go to so many different
places and have all of these different
sort of plot turns that eventually lead
into each other it's really beautiful
how the plot sort of weaves in and out
of itself and culminates in
the ending you see on screen
yeah and the way that we've been able to
follow this family dynamic for three
seasons really makes it feel like
every season you get to pad out more and
more and more about what these
relationships are like
i want to ask about the story with
victor coming out how important was that
for you all to get that right
i mean i think
the writers did an incredible job of
keeping it um
sensitive and authentic
um and
so i think we were just really happy to
see
them
have this story and us just be proud of
being in such an inclusive show yeah
uh you both also get into a lot of
action in this season
uh how much do you look forward to those
fight scene days is it something you
look forward to or is there a bit of
dread about how it's gonna go and how
are you gonna feel after
love them yeah i think we very much look
forward to it there's a
there's a bit this season which like
took quite a lot of time fight
choreography wise
uh well actually yeah
it kind of kept getting pushed
and that was so much fun and because it
kept getting pushed me and aiden would
come in with like new ideas every time
so it just kind of got like bigger and
bigger and longer yeah which we were
really happy about it's it's kind of
jason bourne in the way that some of the
moves occur so
yeah that was fun it was a lot of fun
it's tough to shoot but it's a great
deal for it yeah
the uh this rivalry between this other
version of the hargreaves family you
know the sparrow academy here uh is a
wonderful thing to watch can you compare
it to any other
popular rivalry be it sports or music or
anything else
is it like an instinct versus backstreet
boys thing oh
i think it's an nsync versus backstreet
voice thing
and we're definitely the backstreet boys
what's that say about the basket boys
well we're watching this we're back
all right that's it yeah
and what we thought was our own house
but it's it's not anymore that's kind of
weird
now this is a spoiler question and we're
gonna we're gonna this is not gonna air
before
the show premieres so i've been wanting
to talk to you guys about this since i
watched that episode
um in the very beginning
you're used to we're used to seeing you
doing fight choreography
dancing they always say is very similar
to fight choreography who among you guys
uh aiden for that big scene in the
beginning
was like surprisingly the best at
getting all that choreo really fast
uh it felt like everyone but me
the day i had a lot of trouble with the
dance sequence that happens the fight
after that uh
i have a small bit with with justin but
yeah that wasn't too difficult
surprisingly the dance was the trickiest
thing to get right
because a lot of those uh a lot of those
footloose moves are
not as easy as they look
they're good
y'all make it look easy that's the poor
part